today is the first january of the new
year so first of all happy new year to
everyone and welcome to this new video
on firm learning today i want to talk
about goal setting on how to set goals
for the new year because i know that at
the end of one year at the start of the
new everyone thinks about what are my
priorities what are my resolutions what
do i want to achieve in the next year
and surely this is also what i am doing
for myself and when i set goals for
myself i like to use the methodology of
okrs objectives and key results this is
the methodology that was first described
by andy grove the legendary ceo of intel
also described in his book high output
management that i will link also below
in case you're interested in it and it's
a methodology that got implemented by
most of the tech companies out there and
also more and more of the old economy
companies are rolling the okr framework
out this way okay r stands for
objectives and key results the idea is
that you do define an objective that you
want to achieve but then also back it up
with some key results things that you
want to see that you want to accomplish
that then load into the objective that
you want to reach when i like to set my
goals i like to cluster them in three
different areas the first is
professional goats second sports and
health goats and then third also
personal growth goats so i will now show
you exactly how i approach this goal
setting for the new year what the things
are that i want to accomplish in the
next year and i do hope that this serves
as a motivation for you as well for the
goals that you might set for yourself so
without further ado let's get into it
this is my goal setting sheet and you
see the three areas that i set my goats
in but let's start with the professional
goats and as some of you know i work for
munich-based proptech company called
building radar of course i have many
goats with building radar as well so for
confidentiality reasons let's not look
into them right now but let's rather
focus on the other side of my profession
and as all of you know watching this
channel i also do have this youtube
channel firm learning for those of you
who see this the first time i'm a former
mckinsey consultant and on my channel i
talk about how to be successful in the
first years of your career i talk about
slight writing tips excel advice other
career related topics consulting
weighted topics so like and subscribe if
this is something that you're interested
in and how the okr system is set up is
that you always start with an objective
so here for instance in the first line
youtube to become the leading career and
consulting creator on youtube but then
you always have the key results so you
measure this objective by achieving
these key results which should be
objective and measurable in the end so
here for instance how many youtube
videos i want to create each week so i
want to continue to create one quality
youtube video every single week and then
i also want to do a couple of additional
things so to ideate and launch a new
content format for youtube so stay tuned
on what that is going to be a trust you
will learn about it soon over the course
of the year if you want to learn more
about what these okrs are all about how
these work i created another video last
year about exactly this topic i will
link it somewhere above here so that i
don't need to repeat myself but you can
just look it up if you're interested in
it by the way if you do like this excel
sheet that are prepared to track the
goals i will offer it for you as a
download of course for free just check
the video description for the download
link and you will get it sent to your
personal inbox overall if i do compare
these goals to the goals that i said a
year ago especially these numeric ones
on subscriber growth i must say that are
significantly underdelivered on some of
them but on the other hand okrs are
supposed to be stretch goals so it's
absolutely okay to not deliver every
single goal here in many ways the last
year has been one of the most successful
most fulfilling years of all times for
me in many different ways so definitely
nothing i can complain about what you
see newly added to this sheet compared
to last year is my presence on tick tock
so i started with tick tock in the last
year i post their educational short form
content and i want of course to further
grow on that so if you're interested to
check out my tic toc presence the handle
is just also firm learning check it out
and let me know what you think about it
last but not least is to create a new
flagship course for firm learning
talking about communications and slide
writing so i know that already talked
about a similar course last year here i
failed frankly to deliver this to you
but now i started and i'm quite advanced
and i'm quite confident that in q1 at
some point you will this new course see
to go live over the course of the last
year i created lots of corporate
training sessions so training sessions
for corporate clients on topics such as
communications slide writing problem
solving skills and all of this content
and learnings i will combine into one
new educational flagship offering the
communications and slide writing course
it will launch soon i prepared a little
mailing list where if you want to learn
more and join that you can sign up just
check out the video description link and
i will send you an exclusive launch
offer as soon as it goes live you will
be the first one hearing about it so
check this out put your name on the list
if you're interested in that overall
also reflecting on my personal
experience having started this youtube
channel in january 2020 i do think that
having side projects like this on top of
your regular job can be quite fulfilling
for me definitely made a big difference
there are many lots of great
opportunities that open up only due to
this that i would never even have
dreamed of when i started all of this in
early 2020 so think about what could be
other projects that you would be open
and willing to do on top of your regular
nine to 5 job if you do find the time
for that and can commit to consistently
deliver on such a project my experience
is that good things will likely come to
you next are my goals in the health and
sports section so even number one for me
is to get back into the running shape
this is one of the areas where i did
significantly under deliver last year i
wanted to run a marathon then the
marathon was cancelled due to the health
situation and this pretty much took away
all the motivation for me to really
engage in a regular running practice
this is what i now want to re-engage in
this year get back into a regular
running practice and then potentially
include three also run a marathon once
again and then the next point is signing
up for a gym so one of the perks of
working at building raider is the
directly next to the office there's a
really high quality gym that almost all
employees attend and is very well
accepted to hit the gym for an hour or
so every single day so i do want to take
advantage of that sign up for the gym
and probably establish a habit of two or
three times per week going to the gym
hitting the gym and getting some
additional training in this way last but
not least my personal growth goals so
even though this is something i did
wanted to complete in the last year i
did not complete my phd yet so one of
these other things where i did not have
the progress that i wanted to have but
this year hopefully will be the year i
did make some significant progress last
year i have now the key paper of my phd
under review with a pretty awesome
journal so let's see whether this goes
through that would be pretty amazing i
will let you know once this is decided
so making some significant progress on
the phd potentially even finishing it
would be pretty insane pretty great so
fingers crossed for that and then i also
have some personal net worth goats so
what i would not consider myself a
frugal person i do like to save my money
to invest it i also made a video about
that i will link it somewhere about here
last year i set myself the goal of
having a 50
saving rate this gold i did achieve so
now i thought let's maybe bump it up a
little bit to 60 let's see how where
this goes and then of course i also have
some specific net worth targets for
obvious reasons i will not disclose them
right here if you want to learn more
about how i think about this topic of
tracking your net worth understanding a
little bit better i will link you
another video above here without the
pretty cool net worth tracker that i
developed there that i offer you there
also to download check that out that's
interesting to you i do think that
tracking your net worth can make a
difference for many people so i
encourage you to check it out and see
whether this makes sense for you as well
so of course all of this is just for
inspiration i trust that your goals will
look vastly different than those that i
put down here for myself what i do think
though is just this conscious effort of
writing down all your goals and all
these areas just going into you and
thinking for yourself what actually the
things are that you want to accomplish
next year this exercise alone will help
you to make really a big step towards
exactly these objectives and just by
doing that i trust you will be already a
big step ahead compared to many other
people who are not doing these things i
hope you found this helpful and
inspiring for your personal goal setting
for the new year as well once again i
offer this template that i use to
describe and track my goals as a
download for you you can just get it by
clicking on the link in the video
description hope this is helpful as
always if you took any value out of this
video at all please hit the like button
for the youtube algorithm and also
subscribe to the channel to stay up to
date on all my content big thanks to all
the members who support the channel
actually did a couple of changes to the
membership program so click the join
button to check this out whether this is
relevant to you my name is heinrich i
release new videos every single saturday
looking forward to talk to you again
next week until then all the best and
bye